well i don't know if he knows anything
about cookies whatsoever that guy he's
rude welcome we're hosting snoop and
martha's very tasty halloween and we're
about to see who makes the better cookie
[Music]
hey everyone it is jesse from the tasty
team and today i'm going to baking up
five celebrity chocolate chip cookie
recipes see which one is actually the
best on today's lineup we have recipes
from martha stewart snoop dogg courtney
kardashian michelle obama and the rock
himself well it's pretty tough
competition my gosh
snoop's a fabulous baker khloe
kardashian she must be amazing and
dwayne
he must have some things up his sleeve i
don't know if michelle has so much time
to bake but i think she likes cookies
everyone on that little list
i bake the most cookies
[Music]
first up is martha stewart she starts by
combining flour baking powder baking
soda and salt and whisking them just
until combined set that aside then in
the bowl of a stand mixer fitted with
the petal attachment combine butter
white sugar and brown sugar and beat
that until nice and fluffy scrape that
down
to that add two eggs and vanilla extract
scrape that down and slowly add your dry
ingredients half at a time just so it
gets completely incorporated and bring
in an insane amount of chocolate chips
this is four and a half cups which seems
like more chocolate than actual dough i
don't think it's an insane amount at all
i sometimes put just big chunks of
chocolate i think everybody's gonna like
it i love the combination of white and
brown sugar
portion that out using a scoop and pop
it in the oven
there you have it martha's classic
chocolate chip cookies they're the
judges it's up to them to say what they
want to say i'm having a chocolate chip
cookie i want it to taste like chocolate
chip i think that number five is my
favorite number one was my favorite
hands down i'm a cookie purist um that
was the best one it wasn't a salad it
wasn't a real estate asian cookie it
wasn't a classy lady cookie
well yeah i mean if i'm number one
that's that's better than being number
two i can't remember i've basically
just destroyed all these cookies and
there's nothing that remains
i think number one the first one
probably was my
probably the best i guess it's
presenting as a chocolate chip cookie
and delivering that
we're talking about chocolate chip
cookies this one is by definition i
think closest to that definition well i
don't know if he knows anything about
cookies whatsoever that guy i mean he
throws cookies around he breaks them up
into crumbs and he's not very nice to
the cookies he's rude
i mean
god bless her
that does not surprise me oh
i'm not surprised i'm not surprised
there you have it martha stewart has the
best chocolate chip cookie recipe call
me marth i love you
you never you've never steered me wrong
martha never
now he likes me just because i won
that's not a good reason i'm not calling
you whoever you are
be sure to watch snoop and martha's very
tasty halloween on peacock
[Music]